this alds rolls on from san diego
california it is a picture-perfect
tuesday night we're at petco park the
home of the san diego padres this year
the home of the american league
postseason ray's yankees we are ready to
roll it's the 2020 american league
division series and there is the six
foot eight inch tyler glass now getting
ready for his first division series
start he was excellent in game two of
the wild card series here's aaron judge
and the yankees did win a garrett cole
game
power river right there as glasnow
strikes out judge
his first k and two up two down big
fastball from tyler glass now here's
luke voight on the first pitch started
then stop that's a swing and a miss
gotta secure it at first with two outs
zunino does and that's a good start for
tyler glass now a couple of k's a
scoreless first now the rays are coming
up against the 21 year old davey garcia
and i think it's worth mentioning again
the youngest starting pitcher ever to
pitch in the postseason for the new york
yankees
whitey ford
was the youngest prior
the great whitey ford rosarina would
swing away
no kidding he's got seven hits already
in this postseason a 3-1 change up by
the way no that one's hit hard right
field on the run is judge going back and
that one is up and it is off the top of
the wall no it's gone they call it a
home run first base umpire took an extra
peek
right field umpire confirmed it
and a rose arena has another
first inning home run
in this division series man oh man what
a story this guy is turning into
john carlos stan
feeling the spike there as stan hits one
heart into right field that's deep and
that one's gone giancarlo stanton hits a
rocket out of here slapped one to that
short porch in right it's just 322 down
there
and giancarlo stanton has homered in
four consecutive playoff games for the
yankees
two-two the
count
and a swing and a miss that was a clean
swing and miss
zunino secures it at first base the
strikeout so two men are out here is
clint frazier
feature for him and down he goes glass
now wipes him out
big breaking ball gets him well that's
jay happ on the bow darren boone that's
right returning the favor to the tampa
bay race going with the opener here
and now j hat will get this second
inning so that's a one inning outing for
davey garcia mike zunino he's got big
power
but he can do that sends it high in the
air to left field
back is frazier looking up and goodbye
two-run home run
mike zunino he is a threat at the plate
for that reason shift is on for gary
sanchez a lot of production from it
cold strike three burned off the edge
98 mile an hour gas from glass now
manuel margot at the plate for the raise
got a runner at first and choi
and margot in the center field that
ball's hit well hicks is on the run and
that ball's gone eddie marco a two-run
blast to center field five to one tampa
bay
here's willy adams now
[Applause]
pounces
fires low and that's down in the right
field line
wendell will stop at third domes on his
way to second
and a nightmare outing for j hat
two on nobody out in this fourth inning
with stanton coming up on a home run
derby here at petco park and he hammers
that one stanton will watch it fly
way out of here oh my goodness
giancarlo stanton with a mammoth home
run and the yankees are right back in it
it's a one-run game three-run home run
for stanton
[Applause]
and a wave adam is got him to chase one
so lemay hughes strikes out another good
block by zunino another strikeout for
glass now judge up there with two outs
oh two pitch and he got a glass now with
his best inning yet
ten strikeouts
in five innings for glass now
rey's had two on with two outs last in
and couldn't score now wendell a speedy
runner at second for kiermeier why is it
good deals and that's a shot back up the
middle base hit here buyer rounding
third headed home is wendell and he will
score
kiermeier with an rbi single
and the rays add to their lead it's now
6-4
austin meadows
the lead-off hitter and the designated
hitter is a 2-1
in the air center field hit pretty well
that goes hicks he's at the wall and
this one's gonna fly out of here
austin meadows with a fist bump he's
gone deep
and the rays extend their lead to seven
to four they were at first and second
with nobody out now two men are out here
he comes
and he got him
nick anderson
strikes out sanchez la mayhew and judge
three big k's
the batting champ at the plate le mayhew
rips one into center field to base it
coming into score or shella torres on
his way to third dj la mayhew extends it
an rbi single for the yankees
and la mayhew will in fact get judged to
the plate oh two pitch judge on the
ground
big hop over at third
wendell makes a play and that's your
ball game the tampa bay rays win game
two